merci beaucoup après 17 ans de procédure
les plaignants crie victoire
c'est une grande victoire pour les
victimes et contre les compagnies de
tabac
jean yves blais est à l'origine de ce
recours collectif mais il ne verra pas
la couleur de l'argent puisqu'il est
mort d'un cancer du poumon en ou 2012
quelques mois après le gain du procès sa
veuve a tenu à réagir quand j'ai appris
la nouvelle j'étais très contente mais
très content h que je suis sûr que jeune
il voulait il voulait gagner les villes
et que tout le monde sache comment ça
peut être méchant l'assiette
le jugement de 276 pages prévoit que
cent mille victimes de la cigarette vont
se partager 15 milliards de dollars
des sommes qui vont varier selon la
gravité de leur maladie
le juge attribue tous les torts aux
compagnies de tabac elles ont commis
quatre fautes précise-t-il
dont celle de ne pas avoir informé les
clients des risques liés à la cigarette
imperial tobacco a aussitôt réagi en
rejetant catégoriquement les conclusions
du juge
imperial tobacco et extrêmement déçue du
jugement de la cour
cela nous démontre que la réalité était
ignoré les gouvernements les
consommateurs adultes connaissait les
risques reliés au tabagisme depuis des
décennies les réactions du public sont
partagées
personnellement je porterai pas plainte
parce que j'achète du tabac et c'est ma
responsabilité quoi mais on ne peut pas
nier qui est quelque chose de la part
des grandes compagnies de tabac qui
clairement promis de lâcher leur
business les compagnies sont
responsables tout ce qui s'est passé des
conséquences du tabagisme
il n'en demeure pas moins que c'est un
nouvel échec pour les compagnies de
tabac qui ont dû verser plus de 200
milliards de dollars à 46 états
américains en 1998 mais la veuve de jean
yves blais n'a qu'un seul message
l'écraser j'allais gagner
les compagnies de tabac ont déjà annoncé
qu'elle en appelleront de la décision
oui catherine est ce que les victimes
peuvent espérer voir un jour la couleur
de cet argent qui leur est dû voilà le
juge a décidé que de toute façon en
partant qu'il y ait appel ou non il y
aura un milliard et les compagnies
devront verser mettre sur la table d'ici
60 jours
dans les faits ces cent mille personnes
qui vont se partager 15 milliards en
fait ce vraiment qu'ils sont malades
et là les sommes vont varier ça va
dépendre de la gravité de la maladie de
24000 à 100 mille dollars à peu près et
dans le cas où les gens sont morts comme
par exemple monsieur blais et bien c'est
sa succession qui va empocher finalement
l'argent de ce recours collectif alors
baissé on encore un sarrau mon dieu oui
ça va être long et recours collectif
c'est toujours long mais c'est une
grande victoire pour ces gens qui
finalement se bat depuis 17 ans c'est
vrai merci beaucoup catherine n'y a pas
de quoi